i'll have the honor of serving with a
fantastic vice president
who you just heard from kamala harris
kamala doug like it or not
you're family you become an honorary
bite and there's no way out
so that was joe biden referring to
somebody called doug
emhoff whom he described as the husband
of kamala harris and we took that all at
face value because we're naive
but we have some breaking reporting to
bring you tonight it comes courtesy of a
blog from northern virginia
called politico six reporters from
politico
worked on this story the piece has this
headline doug emhoff
rebrands the second gentleman douglas
according to politico doug imhoff is now
going by douglas as you'd expect the
white house is trying to downplay this
bombshell change a spokesperson for
amhof told politico that the story was
quote bizarre and the quote his name is
douglas m hoff safe to see like most
people his full and abbreviate names
have always been used
interchangeably what does that mean
exactly
one editorial note by the way before we
continue this show in the interest of
accuracy will cease referring
to the white house or anything
associated with the entire executive
branch of government
as the quote biden administration and
the reason we're changing is not to make
a statement but merely to reflect
reality joe biden whatever his merits as
a human being
has no active role in running the us
government everyone knows that everyone
pretends otherwise
but it's true and so henceforth we'll
refer to it as the administration the
white house the kamal harris
administration
the third and far more radical obama
administration this group of people that
susan rice seems to be in control of or
whatever something precise and accurate
but no longer we refer to it
as the bite administration because it's
not
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else